Hey! Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
Last year, you saw us renovating this ruin.
We took out the old roof and restored the brick walls.
We built the wooden frame inside,
with a new roof with reused tiles and insulated with cork..
We then finished it withsome nice-looking, local wood.
This year, we've been using the top floor as an office.
But, we stillhave two rooms in the bottom
that we need to change up...
In this video, we will renew one of them
toconvert it in a tiny cozy room.
But, before we do that, we will help our neighbor right there
to harvestsome hay from our big grass patch.
Our land has two big fields.
Currently, grass is growing andonce a year
our neighbor Jorge comes to cut it.
We already harvested a bit before!
Wegot some hay for our new compost toilet.
Today, we are going tohelp him harvest the rest.
For us, it's nice, because whiledoing this once a year...
What about the kid?
His name is Diogo, and he likes to help Jorge on the land.
He would also like to be in YouTube, so there you go.
This field wasenough to fill more than six of these with hay!
First batch: done.
Let's go for the second round!
It's nice that we can help theneighbors with simple things.
Now, they have a good amount of hay,
that theycan use to feed their animals during winter.
Next, time to go a bit up on theland and
see what we can do in the ruin!
So far, we just reinforced this area and installed two windows,
but we left everything else quiteraw.
We used to use this space for storing ouroff-cuts of wood,
and a bit of other materials that needs to stay dry...
But now, it's time to give another meaning to this space.
The first step is to clean everything out.
But, before we do that, let meintroduce Ruben to you.
He will be the artist.
- Hey! My name is Ruben!
I am from theNetherlands, and I am a carpenter and a builder.
I came to Project Kamp, because I wanted totry community living,
working in nature, and learning about sustainable construction.
I willbe here to help renovating the bottom of the ruin.
Back home, I'm used to building thingsin a certain way
and fast and efficient, but not very sustainable...
So, I wanted to see howthings are done over here.
Let's get started.
- So, the first step is to take allthese leftover wood out of the room.
- You all right?
Yeah, all fine!
After taking all the wood out,
we can see the state of the room.
The floor is full of rubble...
This was probablyonce a big slab of concrete.
We don't know...
As we want to make anew wooden floor, we will take it out.
Removing this will hopefully also
make the floor of the room a bit higher.
This piece of concrete was in good state, butwe can't
do anything withit, so we had to take it out.
Okay, so, now we have cleared out all the bottomof the ruin.
An amazing job.
It's already looking way bigger now!
So, we'll see what has been done inside.
Now,we've already leveled the bottom.
We see that it's way higher than we
thought before, whichis cool!
We have a bit of a challenge here,
because the walls are raw and different fromeach other.
On one side, we have a huge granite wall!
We will probably patch this up with cement.
You can findeven some roof tiles tucked in it!
A bit of a funny job they made here...
On this side,we again have like a brick wall
with some cement brought onto it.
Some bricks, and some granite.
It's a cool mix!
We'llsee what we do with it.
In the front side, which is the south side of the house...
We have a bit ofa similar situation, with the granite wall until here
and everything up here is all bricks.
Wereinforced this before.
In the roof, we find bricks with concrete lintels.
On top, in the office,
there is a cement slab all over the floor.
So, we know what is on top,
because we already renewed the top part of this ruin.
It's time to see what we're gonna do here.
- So, we just want to make it to a nice usable room, you know?
A cool place in summer, because the temperature over here
is a lot better here than the outside temperature...
We're gonna put some concrete posts all overthe room.
We will lay a wooden decked floor on it.
Then, on top of that, we're gonna reuse an oak floor
from an old basketball gym from the nearby area.
We're gonna have a lovely room over here!
- We are buildingthis floor as a platform on top of the ground.
We have put some concrete blocks to level certain points properly,
that would help us level our floor.
Then, we will make the wooden frame
that would support our platform.
- Let's see how it then comes together.
Our platform is made with an all sports cord flow.
It is high quality woodand it was claimed in a nearby town.
We are working very fast!
- Perfect!
Floor: done!
So, as a next step, we're gonna build the doorand a door frame.
We're gonna cut it ourselves,
and then we're gonna put in a40 millimeter door
It'll be made out of leftover materials from other projects
and it's gonnalook really nice.
Alright, so, we have a red cedar beam.
We're going to cut it in half, and then
we're going to make the door frame out of it.
There'salready some markings, so it's gonna be just cut in half.
We then take this piece out forthe door to fall into,
and that's pretty much it!
So, we have made a frame out of the cedar,
and now we're gonna look if it fits.
- Does it fit, Ruben?
We're working with theruin, I guess?
This is the best we can get it.
We're gonna put granite slabs on the sides,
so there'lljust be a fine line left of the window seal that you can see.
Because of the rainfall, we'regonna have it after the wall actually.
Just so there's no rain coming in
and the walls are a little bit off...
They're a bit plump.
But, I guess we can make it work!
- Cool!
In order to attach the door, we first need to build the wall frames.
What do you think about it?
Is it strong enough?
- The house?
Well, after I build this, it's alittle bit stronger.
But, I don't know if the house is very strong!
I think the thingswe build over here however are very strong indeed.
So, the largest part of the ruin is now ready.
We have the door right here,
and I'm now gonnaput the last touches on the door.
So, I'm sanding it, putting in the hinges and lock,
and then it's ready for painting.
We were looking for reused glass for putting in the door.
We found two beautiful small ones
thatwould fit exactly in the door.
But, you know...
As it is, you know that when we reuse materials...
When wetry to get them, we find out that the other one is broken.
So, that's verysad...
We looked somewhere else and we found two nice small ones,
that we're gonna use next to the larger one.
So, it won't work out in the end, I guess.
We only put two screws in, as you can see.
So, the one in the middle, we're not putting it in
if we might need to move the hinge a little bit.
We can loosen these two up, and then redirect the hinge.
We will put in the lastscrew in
and then screw these two down again.
Well, it all fits perfectly!
We have alock now, so we can lock it.
we still need to put the glass in
The next step is goingto be putting in the band,
just so that the glass can be stuck in it.
So, we're just gonna put it in likethat...
We then try to cut it out with a knife.
- Door: done!
We're almost there!
- So, we are all done withframing now.
We've put up all the frames, as you can see.
Now, we're gonna insulate it with50 millimeter cork insulation.
We will do it all around the frame, so that the room will be nice and warm
during winter and nice and cold during the summer.
- At the same time, Jaime is helping with the electricity.
The room is almost ready.
We've put in the corkinsulation.
We did all of the wiring in the room.
We've almost put all of the sockets in.
Now, it'stime for the next step!
That will be the wall paneling.
For that, we're gonna use a 22millimeters thick pine floorboard.
It has a real nice quality and has a goodfinish on it!
Also, it's a tongue and groove, so it fits nice into each other
and it willgive you room some extra strength overall.
All right! All done!
That was it for the walls!
Now, we're gonna do the trim for the windows.
We're gonna do it with the same boards thatwe used for the walls.
We put them upright like that, and make them a little longer.
Also, some trimaround it, so it all looks similar to the walls.
Perfect!
It fits like a glove!
That was the last piece!
The roomis done now!
All the sidings are up.
The floor is nicely in.
And,yeah, that's it!
My job is done!
So, that was it.
it's all finished now!
All the wood is in.
It was a lot of work in a small time, but I reallyenjoyed
working outside and being in nature all day working with wood.
But, mytime is up...
It's time to hit the road again!
- This room is usable and very cozy.
Eventhough it's not completely finished yet, we are already using it!
From work, to taking a nap, doingyoga, having meetings,
and letting the bread dough rest.
This is all possible, because the temperatureinside is very stable.
All thanks to the big granite wall
and the new cork-isolated ones!
But,there's still work to be done...
Such as the ceiling, finishing the electric connections andlights.
We will keep you updated on that!
You often see us building new things on the land.
But, a bigpart of our work is also repairing
and maintaining these things.
The conditions here are quite rough
and certain things tend to wear out, like gloves...
- So, as a part of our work, General Help is cleaningup the land.
Very often, we end up having to pick through
these brambly bushes as well asthe very spiky kojo.
This can, of course, lead to our gloves getting quite torn and ripped.
So, Iam on a mission to find a way to easily fix them for all of us.
I've essentially divided out thegloves into two piles.
On the left, we have the gloves that need to be repaired.
Hereon the right, you have gloves that are,
at this point, beyond repair.
But, we are keeping themaround, as you can see.
They still have some good material on them,
so we can use themas patches for the gloves that we CAN fix.
When it comes to repairing these gloves by sewing...
Generally, what I like to do is doubling up the thread
to make sure that every stitchis stronger.
I will also stitch a knot every single time
to ensure that, in case this getscut while someone is working...
All of the other stitches will still retain their hold on theglove,
and it can still be usable while they'reworking.
For these repairs, I am using a verysimple sewing needle.
One which is, admittedly, a bit too small for leather.
I am using thisblack nylon thread.
I choose nylon, because I find that it is
a lot strongerthan normal thread.
And, just a pair of scissors.
So, the positives here in sewing these gloves
is that it's quite a simple process.
It can be done pretty much by anybody,
and it's alsogenerally, environmental friendly.
As of course, we're extending the lifespan of the gloves.
We're also not using any chemicals or anything
that might harm the earth around us.
The onlydownside is that because the gloves are used
in the manner that you've seen already...
It meansthat these can tear again quite easily.
Especially, at the point where they were repaired.
In thecase of some of these gloves,
the holes are too big and the material has frayed so much.
The sewing of it will really not help
as the material is already too weak...
So, in these cases, we needto cut away
the weak material and use a patch.
For this, I discovered something in theworkspace.
Come with me.
So, tucked away in the back of the workspace, we have a crate, which isfull of all of our glues and different solvents.
In here, I found this product.
It's a typeof glue that you can use for all sorts of clothing materials.
And, in general, it's very good for gluing leather.
So, we're going to be using this
to patch up the gloves with the bigger holes.
All weneed is a bit of sandpaper
and I'll show you why in a second.
So, here we have everything that we need for this repair.
We have the glove turned inside out.
We have the little patch which I tookfrom another glove.
We have the glue, and we have some sanding paper or a sanding disk.
Basically,what we need to do is to first sand both pieces
in order to remove all of the dirt.
To make surethat the material really adheres to the glue.
We apply it to the patch.
And, weapply it to the glove.
We let it sit for about five minutes.
Onlythen I will put the patch onto the glove itself.
Now, the challenge here is that when you
try toput pressure on the patch...
It can very easily glue to the other side of the glove...
So,for that, I take this big stick
and I actually insert it into the glove.
To sort of replicate whatit's like when a finger is in there.
Then, it's easier to apply the patch
and to put pressurewhile it dries.
The plus side of using the glue is that
it's much easier than sewing.
It cancreate a much stronger bond as well in some cases.
It is also easier when we're using patches,
because this material is quite thick.
As you can see with this needle, I have already bentit almost
completely in half, by just trying to sew through two layers.
So,the glue makes ita lot easier in that regard.
The downside is, of course, because it is so full of chemicals,
itis a lot less environmental friendly...
This has started to cure
and now we can attach the twopieces just like that!
We're ensuring that the glued contacts are touching.
Then, we make sure toput some pressure for about a minute or so,
and then we can leave it and let it cure on its own.
That of itself is the whole process.
- New gloves there, huh?
Yeah!
- Wow!
So, we've had sometime to use
some of the gloves that I repaired.
As predicted withthe sewing only,
you can see that because of the work that we're doing...
It becomes frayedand a lot of the knots start to break.
When it comes to using just the glue,
althoughthe patch is still holding...
I'm seeing that the surrounding fabric is starting to fray.
Ihave a feeling or a suspicion that it will not hold for very long
So, what I did with one ofthese is that I used both.
Essentially, I sewed a patch in,
and then I applied glue over top of that.
That seems to be holding up the best!
So, this is what we're going to continue using.
In the caseof these more hardcore repairs,
where you have big holes and things that need to be filled.
- So, itfeels that these gloves are holding quite well!
It's really nice to have almost brand newgloves.
Thank you Alan for the repairs!
It feel very solid!
They're really cool.
In the next video, we willupgrade
the worst thing we have in Project Kamp!
This worn-out, falling apart, plastic, white tent...
You can subscribe on Patreon, and see itright now.
Otherwise, you can always subscribe to our channel,
and comment to keep up our algorithm!
That's it! See you in the next update!